well let me welcome all of you to this
workshop it's a real pleasure to have
such a great group participating here
I'd also like to thank like kraaho Ted
Simons Foundation for hosting it and
Dario for supporting it and then you
have the great man so congratulations to
John and knowing John of course
retirement means nothing he's exact so I
think I first met John I think around
1984 or so I took a class from him I
remember and I've known him for almost
like 60% of my life and called him as a
close friend
apart from being a colleague and it's
been one of the high points so far so my
job here right now is just to serve as
as I guess they must have sent me to the
first two lectures and the first speaker
is going to be Professor peoc remark
looking around me and seeing this crowd
I think it's perfectly obvious that
Kumar needs no introduction so I guess
all I'd say is that he was already a
legend in research when I was a graduate
student so that should give you some
idea of how great he is and he's always
been held up by internal discussions as
one of the exemplars of research style
is released three major things that all
of us know about so one is definitely
work in adaptive control from his early
career then always work on manufacturing
lines where these fantastic lucuma are
counter examples and various questions
that are still being studied and then
more recently the work on scaling laws
for wireless networks and there's lots
of research topics that have had a huge
impact I am also leaving our so on that
note let me
I don't need this
so it's John's retirement but I think
people for people like John and Praveen
and all this what retirement doesn't
mean retirement it probably just means
that you won't have a class every
semester and I'm sure he'll be applying
to deadia for contracts and so yeah so
we need to redefine this word okay so
you know John has had a illustrious
career of research achievements and I
just thought I'd mention a few of them
that I mean to me are just things that
I'll always remember beautiful early
work on flows in queueing networks
characterizing when they're posed now
when delays are independent there's this
non overtaking condition and this little
gem of a work I really like ami enough
all of you in ho queuing networks know
that if you have feedback the process is
not Poisson and it's always a mystery
and why is it it's a horrible process it
is not McCartney or none of those things
but yet it has this geometric
steady-state distribution and I think
John's beautifully simple explanation of
adding a delay and then taking the delay
going to zero it's just fantastic so
very unnoticed thing small note probably
but a juror okay then all this very nice
work on quick simulation with sham break
and so on swapping of rivals and also
very elegant use of coupling etc to
prove results in fact there was a paper
about 40 years ago so that me and my
student wrote a humongous long paper and
I think John folded up today I ran a
couple page short proof a special
coupling fantastic multi-armed bandit
again simple proof interchange even to
that well studied area their proof was
very very nice then of course more
recently or now CSMA seminal
on Macs wait for switches in the early
days of ATM god knows what happened to
ATM but decoupling I think it lives on
in MPLS or something like that
decoupling bandwidth this notion and
then more recently network security
economics of network network games and
so on and so forth but more also then
the research he's also been a role model
for research values okay not just in in
what is a minimum publishable unit but
also in the presentation style and very
high standard for theoretical results
role model for research his papers are
completely Sean of adornment in fact I
was tempted to coin a word today and
define a new word so somebody if you
want to use this in future works credit
limited wall run I said this is the
antonym of the word hype and that's not
just hype doesn't mean under the
opposite doesn't mean under statement
there's also some beautiful simplicity
getting to the heart of the matter
etc so his all his papers I just
absolutely to the point okay explain get
to the key idea in the simplest possible
way no sentence is wasted but that also
means that you have to read each and
every sentence don't skip one sentence
oh you miss a whole chapter and somebody
else's book and in the same style lots
and lots of books okay again and
exemplary understatement modesty so to
wall round is the antonym for Hyper okay
and this I put there exclamation mark
because I would not have bet a penny on
this but he's also been a very
successful entrepreneur and continuously
held aloft very high standards for
everybody to emulate both in research
and dissemination fantastic and it's a
great honor to have known him for so
many decades it's a smaller percentage
of my life than when cats but
okay so you know long time ago I was
giving a talk we had a Murie we had a
couple of munis nestor offered me rita
on our movie and we used to have
presentations and i was given one talk
once on some delays or something and
John asked me what about the strategic
kiss at that time I didn't have an
answer but in a totally different area
we look at some strategic things so I
thought I would talk about that and as
you all know this is the work of my
student Khaimah who is somewhere where
are you okay is there so any questions
please ask him and okay so what is this
problem so it's motivated by the problem
of power systems so there are many many
generators and loads as nuclear power
plants there's cold as wind as hydro
power and there's many loads you can
have storage services which may store
and sell industrial loads commercial
loads load serving entities which are
aggregators of many many small nodes
like an Internet service provider or
something and they all have different
dynamics uncertainties costs and rewards
so for example nuclear power plants like
to maintain a constant output coal power
plants you may want you can ramp them up
but they may take a certain time so
there's yet make decision so I'm going
to start ramping and so on wind random
hydropower also random okay load serving
entities so so this is a like Internet
service provider you collect together a
bunch of smaller loads say homes and
then you exploit the flexibility on when
to turn ACS on or off etc and then
thereby you try to match supply because
big name of the game and use renewable
power is that you cannot adjust supply
so you have to change demand to accept
like so these are trying some kind of an
aggregator model then you have
commercial models so commercial company
like Walmart may decide to pre-cool its
it's a store in the morning and then cut
it down at in the afternoon when it's
not power is not expensive and they turn
it off entirely at night whereas an
industrial load me
do something else a storage service may
decide to buy power than the price is
low and then sell it when it's high and
so on so there are many many many
entities and the point is that by and
large you need to Jen you need to
exactly balance power and generation and
consumption you can soar in the inertia
of the generators and also in the
heating of the transmission line but by
and large you have to maintain balance
at all times so you have all these
stochastic entities some controllable
some not that you have to balance and
there is a thing called a system
operator in the u.s. it's in in many
places an Independent System Operator
called the sitting right there is so and
that the job of that system operator is
to maintain balance at all times but
maximize social welfare social welfare
is the sum of the wealth utilities of
everybody ok and we also have some
objectives we don't want to subsidize so
we want to maintain budget balance and
also things like individual rationality
that is some of the pricing structure
should be that people will participate
in the market not not drop out and also
even though there are things like which
ensure truth-telling you want to charge
a fair price so I'm going to call that
you want to charge the Lagrange
multiplier okay so I'm going to call
that LaGrant optimality and you need to
do that without knowing the details of
all these entities the details of their
models their internal state stochastics
etcetera now of course I also can ask
them but they can like example and wrong
and so the question is how can the
system operator alright that's a
fundamental problem that K has been
looking at so the mathematical problem
is there's a bunch of stochastic
dynamical system standard state control
noise and the social planners goal is to
maximize the there's a finite time
horizon there are a capital N agents
this is the utilities of the agents and
it wants to maximize the sum of the
utility over a horizon of all the agents
and while maintaining balance at all
times
okay total consumption equals generation
without knowing dynamics utility
function States etc so that's the
problem now in the deterministic case
there is there are solutions for this
suppose the agent has a utility function
and it can lie and bid some other
utility function then all of you are
familiar with with VCG mechanisms so we
can construct a mechanism where the
agent has to pay a price PA make a
payment P I and the net utility or the
quasi-linear util net utility is the
utility derives from the consumption
generation - the payment okay and the
allocation so after these people bid the
the sort of the central planner chooses
the allocation to maximize the
social welfare or the reported social
welfare and this payment you'd like to
define define it in such a way that each
age and internal internalizes the social
externality okay
and so the VCG mechanism has a certain
form of a payment structure okay
basically as I said you internalize
other people's utility and it ensures
incentive compatibility that is
truth-telling is a dominant strategy and
if and if it is unique then you will do
that okay assuming some kind of
rationality maximize the social
efficient it's a socially efficient that
means it maximizes social welfare and
there's a more general mechanism where
this part of the payment can be any
function not including eyes on reported
utility okay so the so this
deterministic static case can be
extended to deterministic dynamic cases
in a very straightforward way simply by
looking at the entire open-loop sequence
as a decision okay so it extends
immediately but and and it extends so
that you when you report I can ask you
to report your dynamics your initial
conditions everything and then I can
answer your truth-telling is optimal
okay but in the stochastic dynamic case
the states of the agents are private
random variables okay and and the social
welfare for optimal allocation I need to
know the states of the of these private
systems okay so the social welfare
planner needs to ensure that agents
reveal their states and in fact this is
the key part because there are
disturbances and randomness occurring
all over the place when you're dealing
with wind and consumers and behavioral
behaviors and so on you want to take
these disturbances into account in
pricing and so on okay
I mean for turbine blade breaks under
some excessive in somewhere or whatever
so so you want them to report the states
their own states okay but that's
difficulty
suppose the we'll consider the case
where the utility function and the
dynamics are known and suppose the
social planner asks the agents report
their states okay then the natural
extension of the VCC mechanism is just
to extend it by taking into account the
cost over the time horizon and putting
in some conditional expectations where u
star is the optimal solution to this
stochastic control problem but the
problem is that truth-telling forms a
sub game perfect Nash equilibrium but
it's not a dominant strategy okay in
other words if everybody else is selling
- then you should respond truthfully but
it's not dominant because you could
declare your states in a stochastically
inconsistently with the dynamics so all
this dynamic programming sort of
optimality that you do does disclose
that at the window so there's a
fundamental obstacle in trying to extend
the VCG
from deterministic to stochastic dynamic
fundamental obstacle okay there's yet
another we are ambitious we all even
want to do more things we also want to
achieve budget balance that is I so
should not need to subsidize the agents
and we want in
so that's budget balance give the total
payments agree to the very good zero
individual rationality means that by
participating you don't get negatives
utility and there's another obstacle
there's no mechanism that can satisfy
all these properties incentive
compatibility maximization of social
welfare budget balance and individual
rationality so that doesn't exist and I
want one more objective I want them to
charge if everybody to be charged a fair
price that is they should be charged
electrons multiplier which would be the
price in the absence of any strategic
considerations
okay okay so what can the social planner
do is there any hope and it turns out
that is hope in almost I think there's
this maybe only case in which there is
hope it turns out that the good old
leave me a quadratic Gaussian problem
I don't even thinking it Gaussian but
the good ol LQG case actually you can
actually extend this theorem so this is
the standard LKG problem
okay I'll be looking at the fully
observed case but you can do it for the
partially observed and I'm going to
denote by capital X you the so the the
idea of incentive so our idea is the
following
ok so each time s there will be a random
disturbance that occurs to every agent
right and I want them to declare their
disturbances so I can price things
properly and make the market efficient
okay that's my goal so so the ISO
charges a VC T payment taking it effect
taking into account the effect of the
disturbance at this particular time on
all future states and balancing for this
particular disturbance so we're going to
do a disturbance my disturbance okay as
we go along in time so we're going to
balance for each disturbance okay and
there is some independence there okay so
we're going to explore all these things
and due to the superposition of these
linear systems the future states can be
written as a sum of the effects of past
disturbances and the quadratic nature of
the cause renders this additional
interaction as a product okay so I'm
kind of product between independent
variables and then we can show an
expectations the expectation that these
things cancel out and this will allow us
to get the X and T results okay but
ex-ante not in a it's little stronger
than the sense that it's still
conditional expectations not just
expectation okay all right so here is
the so that's a broad idea and the
solution is the following we call this
in a
DCG mechanism will ask agents to bid
their state their noises at time s minus
one and then what we'll do is we
propagate the system forward from this
noise together with allocations which
are based on this noise okay and the
trajectory resulting from the particular
disturbance at that time can be thought
of and then the superposition of these
things would be the total state so you
look at all previous disturbances and
look at their effect at time T that'll
be their the state so that superposition
and then similarly will also decompose
the allocations okay so that the total
allocation that is consumption
generation is a sum of the allocations
new to the individual disturbances so in
a similar way the random social welfare
that is without the expectation you can
write it as the sum of layers of random
social welfare in this way but then
there are quadratics okay because the
state at time T is a superposition of
many effects and we take quadratics
you'll get cross terms okay so there are
cross terms of this sort they can only
be eliminated in expectation and that is
what I meant by X so so basically the
scheme is the agent I bids a state which
is effectively the noise at time s the
social plan max maximizes the utility of
that layer if you will and collects a
payment in the standard VCG sort of a
way or a groves sort of way and now in
order to make this thing through we need
to for the agents to be rational okay so
what's the definition of rationality we
need okay so it's like they need to be
persistently rational so in what sense
so let's I'm going to define this by
backward induction what I mean by
rationality I'll say that an agent at
almost at the very end is rational
if there is a unique if there is a
unique dominant strategy then it'll use
that okay so that's my definition of
rationality at time t minus one but the
uniqueness will come in because of the
positive definiteness of the cost okay
all right and then we will say that it's
rational at time T if it adopts a unique
dominant strategy at time T when there
is one under the assumption that all
agents will be rational at future times
okay so under this persistent
rationality assumption to telling is a
dominant strategy okay but in the
stochastic case we do need to know the
system dynamics and so on in fact
there's a counter example of the
dynamics are not so unlike the
deterministic case the next question is
so this may be the only case that you
can do the strategic problem in the
stochastic dynamic case that I know okay
now but we also want to go after budget
budget balance and individual
rationality so how to ensure that this
layered VCG payments satisfy budget
balance in individual rationality very
simple I'm going to scale up the first
groves term in the in the payment by a
factor C to try to achieve this balance
so you simply scale that okay well this
actually the VCG scheme and that's what
we call the scaled DCT mechanism so this
is an example of groves now okay now we
would like to choose this C to achieve
balance so we'd like to do one parameter
scaling of these payments is a constancy
for everybody okay but if C is chosen as
a function of the bids then we lose the
gross property because this has to not
depend on agent eyes bit okay all right
so however what we can show is that
under a certain market power balance
which which I'll define in a second it
turns out that there's a range of values
of C that ensures a budget balance in
individual rationality
and the hope is that because these
agents are always interacting in the
marketplace right the icer is doing this
running this auction everyday right
hopefully it can get a knowledge of the
range of C's that work or tune it to get
budget balance okay it's not just unique
value it's actually a range so that's
the hope and what is this market power
balance condition
so take the optimal solution that agent
I excluded the optimal report and look
at the maximum so basically this maximum
is the social welfare of everybody - the
least the smallest fish okay in the pool
and we'd say that the outcome satisfies
market power balance if the number of
agents minus one times the max is less
than this so basically the way to
interpret it is that no one agent has a
humongous effect okay or too little an
effect okay the theorem is that if the
socially optimal outcome satisfies
market power balance then there is
indeed a range of C's of tuning this
parameter such that the scaled VCG
mechanism is incentive compatible
efficient budget balance and
individuation all at the same time and
perhaps you can think of this market
power balance condition as an economic
justification for lured aggregators so
you don't want these individual homes to
participate in marketplace they're too
small of fry and if you aggregate them
so that they all have kind of equal
cloud more or less then then you can
actually get socialization but we also
want more we also want to have to pay
the fair price okay
Lagrange multiplier so we have an
asymptotic becomes asymptotic Lagrange
optimality so the grand optimality
simply means that for the constraint
problem if there's a unique solution for
a unique solution then the payment that
you make is actually the payment of the
the price of the Lagrange multiplier
times them the
okay and what we can show is that if if
some of these things are bounded all
these agents then asymptotically the
number of agents increases there is a
range for each and and these things
satisfy the fact that they converged one
okay and we can get actually has a
Lagrange optimality so as things scale
up you get exactly if you have a large
number of equally somewhat equally
powerful contenders in this market power
value since then you get to give me the
fair price for everybody so some
thoughts okay on what this scheme is so
today's bidding is essentially static
okay and it doesn't allow for a really
genuine dynamic optimization of
uncertain resources so we want to
exploit wind to the health we won't
exploit renewables to the hilt but we
also want to exploit the flexibility of
consumers and so on and all that is
dynamic and stochastic and it doesn't
really allow that
so maybe wasteful of resources so we
definitely need a stochastic dynamic
bidding scheme okay now on the other
hand we also want to satisfy incentive
compatibility social welfare optimality
budget balance individual rationality
and the correct price cream and some
kind of fairness
so I call the Lagrange optimality now so
here's a proposal proposal is large LQG
systems can today be soft so even if you
are an ISO and you have a thousand
people submitting LQG then perhaps
computationally this should be feasible
now this computer and so can lqg become
the workhorse of dynamic stochastic
bidding yeah that's the suggestion and
there is some kind of precedent to that
I mean if you look at open any text book
on power systems there'll be the cost of
when they explain economic dispatch
anything like that they'll always talk
of the cost of generating of power P as
a quadratic okay so talk to my power
system PR linear quadratic sums
so and in the deterministic case just
tuning just one parameter can achieve
all of this just one parameter and is
this is it possible that because of
repeated interactions the prior
knowledge that you acquire is that in
after tune C and perhaps maybe of course
but if the game that learning also let
me get it today okay but is that a
possibility and does this market power
balance condition for Social Welfare
maximization provide economic
justification for full or aggregators as
as agents to permit social welfare
maximization and khaimah is
investigating all these things at his
new job in ok so again John thank you
for following you to be here and I wish
you the very best and continued success
[Applause]
aunty but in a conditional expectation
sense but so so let's think of ex post
as almost surely ex ante as expected
value so this is ex ante but condition
expectation so this is not in general
I'm saying that given this system there
is a range and you want to tune in that
range if you say all systems then
there's an empty so there is prior
knowledge and the question is can you
use prior knowledge to do these things
yeah I'm just wondering about the impact
of the number of market players just
writing this paper so I think with the
convergence rate graph with the
convergence rate right
one over in okay this yeah I think it's
like give you these properties for the
steering system as well be sitting if
you have the yeah yeah
so yeah exactly it would it would so in
the for example the deterministic and
cue problems powerful or weak you have
to interpret this properly
yeah basic in the agents are roughly
it's not you're not comparing equation
big question you're just saying in this
influence exert on the market at the end
of the day given that dynamics and
utilities and so on the kind of
comparable so just coming back to the
budget balance individual russian is
that every time step for this no
actually in the way we do it is we do
for every layer I mean that's stronger
than what you would need if you just
wanted to completely exam to it but
actually does
I mean I guess the one thing this also
the bogeyman body might be that
mechanism which would operate in this
context Howard what you have compared
with what they don't know that depends
on using the fact that is an optimal
running they don't get that budget
balanced over power it's like a standard
BCG version you can take one person it's
depressing
[Applause]